of course there are plans to reboot
another 1980s classic TV show from my
childhood this time it's Airwolf
quite excited about that welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so to give you a little bit of an
Insight of my childhood
I spent an awful lot of time watching TV
and playing Lego that was that was
basically my life for far too many years
and a lot of Saturday mornings what I
would do is sit and watch Airwolf and
then build the Airwolf out of Lego
and that's how I spent many many
Saturday mornings
why because the TV show was brilliant
and it does look like from what I'm
being told by a colleague of mine that
works actually now at NBC that we might
actually get a reboot of this classic
show
now there's been rumors about a reboot
for quite a while and it is actually an
anniversary next year of when the show
first appeared on our screens
so it makes sense that rumors would be
swirling that if there's a big rumor
about a big reunion potentially
um and that would be very very cool to
see
but the rumor at the moment is that
actually early development for a new TV
show has recently started and that is
serious development that they really
want to try to get this to our screens
so before I tell you what the rumor is
in full and what they're looking at
doing I want to tell you a little bit
about the original show because it was
at least in the beginning absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
so why was the TV show so brilliant well
it only actually aired for three years
1940 1987. it did have four seasons but
the fourth series with Dick Van Dyke's
kid in it Barry we could forget about
that I've never watched it I think I
might watch one or two episodes it was
Bloody awful so let's forget that over
existed this series was based around
this super secretive supersonic stealth
helicopter it was basically Knight Rider
for the sky except it didn't talk so
much the story of how the Airwolf was
actually created there was a little bit
different it was actually invented and
built by Charles Henry Moffett who was a
psychopath which shows really how this
first series of Airwolf did go a little
darker than I was expecting it went on
in the second half of the second series
to become a far more friendly show at
the bequest of the executives at NBC and
which kind of ruined it for me
um but early on it was seriously a
little bit dark this guy Moffett built
it for the CIA as a secret weapon that
they were going to use and then he stole
it and he took it to Libyan
libyans this was a period where the
libyans were actively causing a little
bit of trouble politically around the
world and they even got themselves into
Back to the Future so we know that at
this time libyans were the Isis of that
generation but anyway during a live fire
test this Moffat guy stole the Airwolf
he actually then fired on the bunker
where all the generals were and killed a
load of people and Archangel got injured
you see the rest of the series with an
eye patch Archangel is sort of like the
CIA guy needs the link that then holds
the rest of the show together later on
and then yeah steals it takes it to
Libya and does a bunch of evil things
for the libyans including sinking a uh
U.S Navy destroyer or cruiser
um and you know doing all these other
terrorist Acts so Archangel then
approached string fellow Hawk who was
one of the greatest names in all of
sci-fi Stringfellow Hawk I mean come on
um he actually was involved in test
flying the Airwolf and he was approached
by Archangel to go and steal a
helicopter back which he did he was
supposed to then give the helicopter
back to the CIA or the firm as they were
called in this but he chose not to
now archangelist took up a deal with him
to get basically you get to keep the
helicopter if you do some admissions for
me but you get to pick and choose those
missions
um and then that's the setup for the
series why was it so great
helicopters are cool aren't they they
just are
um the Airwolf is very cool I mean they
have actually built this helicopter into
replicas and put it in several air
museums around the world because it is
such an iconic shape I mean the
helicopter is actually based on is a
beautiful helicopter in itself and it's
one of those helicopters you get to see
all the time
the theme music is Iconic
who says a picture doesn't have music
just you cannot look at this image and
not seeing the theme tune in your head
if you are a certain age like myself
foreign
[Music]
it was just one of those actors that's
just immediately likable
um he played Dominic Santini he's just
got one of those faces that you just
trust
and yeah he was a big part of why the
show was successful as well
so what am I being told about a reboot
well this is in the hands of NBC at the
moment if it goes into production the
plan is that it'll go onto the peacock
Network it's very very early development
at the moment they're trying to figure
out if they want to do it how are they
going to do it because
in its original format a stealthy
supersonic helicopter
um won't work I don't think technology
has moved to the point now where with
drones Etc and actually we have
helicopters that are nearly as capable
as the Airwolf
um I just think about how there's an
actually an episode in Airwolf where
there's a red Airwolf to the sequel and
it's got a laser mount underneath
instead of the rockets that used to come
out and popped out the belly of the
Airwolf
um I'd actually think about that as
almost like
that was only after a couple of years
we've superseded it actually this has
gone out of sci-fi in almost a common
science fact other than the supersonic
bit which is another point you have to
make about this actually the audiences
nowadays are a bit more Savvy and thanks
to YouTube and whatever else as well
that if they do anything in this show
that's just like not
um aerodynamically possible somebody
will call them out for it and a
helicopter cannot actually travel at
supersonic speeds the the rotor blades
create downlift and they wouldn't it
just wouldn't work and it's not possible
and what you would have to do is do more
like a ospro type thing where the hell
the engines move and you go forward and
there's ways you could make a vehicle
like this but it wouldn't be a
helicopter so I think technologically
they're going to be very careful about
what the Airwolf actually is could it
even be some sort of drone or could they
bring in some sort of artificial
intelligence element to this which is
the next step in the evolution addition
of drones that can actually fly
themselves I wonder if Airwolf could
actually be something more along those
lines that it's Ai and human together in
some sort of hybrid
um that would be maybe a little bit more
color and it would be still Science
Fiction it's like it's just talking
about stuff that might be possible in 10
or 15 20 years time Airwolf
is already been surpassed now so they'd
have to do something a little bit
different I'm wondering even if you
maybe they don't do a helicopter
um
I think something more along the lines
of a drone would might possibly make
more sense but that's just me thinking
out loud I do think politically we're in
a position worldwide where if they go
along a similar sort of lines as they
did in the original series that there is
this new experimental aircraft
um it gets stolen by the Creator they do
some terrorism
um you know then it comes back but the
pilot who captures the aircraft back
doesn't trust the government to actually
behave for this thing and they can't
rebuild it for whatever reason the
government I don't know whether they
just have the schematics is build a load
more but they don't for whatever reason
and you know and then this guy hides the
aircraft and does special missions under
the books whatever that actually
storyline could work in today's world
particularly because of the political
situation we're in at the moment I think
there's lots of different directions a
story like that could go another thing
talking about the technology very
quickly is though that
this show was actually incredibly
expensive to make back in the 80s loads
of helicopters flying around they do did
lots of helicopter stunts but then they
used the shots over and over again it
was one of the weaknesses of the show
really because even me as a kid I'm
watching it going well I've seen this
shot before I've seen this whole
sequence before they've just done a
different angle on it or something or
re-edited it slightly with technology
now now with CGI and stuff that we could
get a more exciting vehicle like a drone
or something else and actually get some
really cool flying effects
the popularity of the top gun Maverick
movie recently as well I think lends
into this that people like that sort of
thing when it looks sort of more
realistic and if they get the tone right
they use the special effects
sparingly and they actually do create
something that looks enough sci-fi
that's not technologically possible
maybe today but still within the grasp
of reality that they could actually
create a show that was really
interesting
so guys get into the comments and tell
me what you think is an air wolf reboot
something you'd want to see
but do you agree with me there's going
to be changed quite a lot for modern
audiences
again in the comments tell me exactly
what you think and if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification really helps us out
also if you enjoy the content don't
forget you can hit that join button and
become a fully fledged side tracker hit
the join button
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time